a death can come at any time
and you don't have to be very active,
very aware, very vigilant, because living
in a country where there is a conflict, that's
how you live
with fear all the time, it
's logical
that no one if we mean
November 24,  2016 is signed
in Havana Cuba- the peace agreement between
the national government and the FARC for the
end of the conflict and the
construction of a stable and
lasting peace more or less 75 percent of
the demobilized of the country that are
about 59  thousand demobilized in the
last 16 15 years
were victims before being victimizers
were recruited as minors
or were involved in the
conflict due to serious violations against
their person
my name is natalia ribera
I am fat I am 20 years old I joined in 2011 to
the farc
bombed us at the company where i
belonged
this was like at 12 o'clock
at night so i remember a lot because my
cove was let's say here and there  dito there lived
a girl who loved her very much,
unfortunately she, well, in
today's bor band that maybe she caught her she slept she
didn't get to vote for the trench and
the investment died it's like this when they
look at it destroyed or saying help me do
n't leave me
yes  sometimes and remember that is the future
[Music]
his vision in the bees process
schuchat his fracture enables of people
that had been symbol of the inba the
cert report and forty years eve you want to win
it aint of aggressive and javier adame large
level we need  to complete change of
intervention process you can provide
hausa work
social security for excombatiente but
the hub trauma dejaba forty years of
experience expulsen to violence or not
only in colombia ba dinh el resto de
world monster rehabilitation' programs
and not evidence-based win it to  get
findings from the government to provide
a strange systematic and rehabilitation
processes regalen to social cognition and
social adaptation the dark casualties more
imp  Important others dimension of the
rehabilitation process 93% of the
people who enter the
reintegration process come with
psychosocial disorders, some more serious than others
and others definitely very serious that
would already pass from the psychosocial to the
psychological and some of these
psychiatric ones have stress
post-traumatic we
have anxiety disorders we have attention deficit
we have a number of diseases that
if they are not taken into account for the
reintegration process the
demobilized person will not advance on his
route my name is wilson young
Galician gentleman I spent 15 years in the farc and
I joined  at
the age of 16
something hard that I had to do and that
bothers me and what and what I do
n't want because
as he is lying down remembering very
constantly it
is the execution people
talking about people that I want from
ordinary civilians who worked for the
enemy
share this with you
because well
because I want the people who
listen to me  Let the people who
see me
feel that they know that this was
not, it was not my own decision, it was not for my
liking, it was not because I am like this,
and above all, they can forgive us, it
was not of their own free will, because it was
a hobby or  why because we like to
do that but because
the lives of all of us are also in danger
doing search and we believe that the
colombian conflict that only
opportunity is the living lab they have
descended real life interwin between
biology psychology and culture to the factor
involved in violence  and criminal big
air
west argued empatitis because we the
beginning of the combats and william levy
in a tie
however we found ages our basic
lewy found dead former rebel combatants
in a tie of the Colombian regular power
soler their empathy kampeter recall not all
of the heart problem without a tie
microsoft research we found love we can
offer from the commander to the commission
training the train and emotional social recognition
recognition theory of mine and
social killed the night recognize
fighting words situation or institution
stop their aggressive activity and javier
attend we can implementation of
intervention into a mental health
approach
I say it
personally 100% I have changed 99
percent because for me I  It seems that the most
difficult thing about being an ex-combatant and ex-combatants,
that is, it ends, is that
many many look at us as weirdos,
like there are terrorists, like things
like that, there is a sign of society at large is not
ready to versions people and we need
a society rehabilitation  process that
is more challenging and providing
individual rehabilitation to
each of the people who are in the
armed conflict for whatever reason
we are human beings we can change
we can be someone in life we can contr
bute to society we can move the c
untry forwa
d together we can do  from a country of
Colombia a much better country
[Music]